What's up, Marvel fans?
We're here with Simu Liu.
What is going on?
We're here at the live carpet.
How does it feel?
It feels pretty great.
I'm-- I'm not sure that
these people realize
that I'm not in this movie.
I think they-- you
know, I'm not going
to burst their bubble for them.
- No spoilers.
No spoilers.
- There are no spoilers at all.
Anything is possible.
But I'm also not in this movie.
Maybe.
So who are you most
excited to see in this film?
I'm excited to see Spider-Man.
No spoilers.
Worst ever Spider-Man
[SOUND EFFECT]??
Question mark?
I'm excited to-- no,
no, I mean, I've been--
I've been reading the
rumors like everybody else.
I'm-- I'm so fortunate
to get to be here, to get
to watch this movie early.
And I'm just excited to
see where they take it.
I-- I've been such a fan of
the-- the Spider-Man movies
ever since Tobey Maguire.
I think it's just been a really
long ride and a full circle
moment for a lot of people.
So I'm-- I'm jazzed.
I'm excited.
Well, talking about that,
previous supervillains
are in this movie.
Yes.
What was your reaction
when you found out?
I was pretty--
OK, well-- well, first of all,
I was like, oh my god, Doctor
Octopus is in the trailer.
And then I was like,
oh my god, like, Jamie
Foxx was there as Electro.
And then it was like, oh
my god, he's got the Stark
tech on his-- on his armor.
So I was like, what
does that mean?
I feel like everyone
was, you know,
pretty blown away by-- by all
of that, I think, you know.
I-- I work for this company.
So I know people at Marvel,
they're master marketers.
They're-- you know,
they're mysterious.
They work in mysterious ways.
They operate behind a-- a
veil of secrecy and shadow.
And-- and, you know, I'm--
I'm just excited.
I'm-- I'm excited
that I finally get
to take a peek behind and see
what they've been cooking up,
you know.
I-- I feel like I--
I deserve to be here because
I used to play Spider-Man
at kid's birthday parties.
I dressed up.
I-- I inhabited the character.
You know, I was in the costume.
I-- I really-- I feel
like I was Spider-Man.
So in a way, I do feel
like this is my premiere.
Could I still hire
you for birthdays?
Or is it too late?
You can.
But the rate is now
$75,000 dollars an hour.
Oh, no.
Yes, it's gone
up a little bit.
It's-- yes.
- Spider-Man.
- Yeah.
- Thank you, Sima.
Have a good one.
Take it easy.
You too.
[MUSIC PLAYING]